c'est une voiture qui se fait arrêter
sur l'autoroute
policier ils arrêtent dis bonjour
monsieur dis bonjour présentez-moi les
papiers présentez le papier dit vous
savez pourquoi vous arrête dit non dis
parce que vous roulez mais pas vite du
tout il dit comment vous roulez pas vite
et ben c'est normal je suis sur la A19
je roule à 19
est-ce possible non mais en fait il voit
qu'il a affaire et d'écouter monsieur à
19 ça n'a rien à voir et que la vitesse
donc là vous pouvez rouler enfin comme
vous voulez il dit par contre votre
femme à côté elle m'a l'air bien blanche
il dit oui on vient de quitter à 330
[Applaudissements]
c'est un mec qui rentre il rentre dans
une banque il prend deux personnes en
otage donc la police le négociateur ils
essaient de calmez-vous monsieur sortez
dit non ma vie c'est de la merde à cause
de cette société je suis énervé votre
façon je vais buter un otage il va il
regarde la femme sa femme elle lui dit
la femme il dit écoutez je suis obligé
de buter un otage d'écouter bah il y a
pas de problème des micro vous appelez
je m'appelle Béatrice et là le mec il
commence à pleurer il pleure avec son
flingue il pleure il me prend vous
pleurez mais parce que mon ex s'appelait
Béatrice la pauvre elle nous a quitté et
le mec à côté du moi je m'appelle Marcel
mais dans le quartier on m'appelle
Béatrice
c'est un couple ça fait
50 ans ils sont mariés accomplir des
trucs
et 15 jours après la femme elle décède
aussi et là ils arrivent au paradis et
la femme elle voit son mari au paradis
elle court elle dit mon amour tu as vu
je te rejoins lui dit écoute Mireille ah
le prêtre il a dit jusqu'à que la mort
nous sépare alors
[Applaudissements]
son pote il dit alors comment tu vas
Charlie
du travail
mais je peux pas t'engager parce que toi
tu bégayes c'est compliqué il dit oui
mais si tu m'engage pas qui qui
va m'engager ouais mais je peux pas
t'engager bref il parle le mec un mois
après il se recroise ça va Charlie
qu'est-ce qu'il devient
trouver du travail
tu bosses où il dit
je suis dans le téléphone
tu commences à ton téléphone mais tu
fais quoi dans le téléphone c'est moi
qui fait le Bip Bip Bip Bip Bip
deux mecs qui discutent ils disent
écoute David tu as déjà trompé ta femme
toi et écoute ça fait 40 ans je suis
marié avec elle je l'ai jamais trompé il
dit par contre je me suis trompé de
femme
[Applaudissements]
mec dans un marché au marché il cherche
sa femme partout il tombe sur un autre
mec il dit qu'est-ce que tu cherches je
te dis moi je cherche ma femme c'est un
truc de fou moi aussi je cherche ma
femme dis mais toi comment elle est ta
femme de ma femme elle est belle elle
est grande elle a les yeux verts elle
m'écoute je l'écoute on s'aime elle est
adorable tiens ta femme comment elle dit
laisse tomber
ah ça fonctionne mon ami
[Applaudissements]
laisse tomber viens on cherche ta femme
c'est une vieille dame qui appelle à
l'hôpital à Thibault et bonjour bonjour
madame qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour
vous je vous appelle pour un
renseignement c'est quoi votre
renseignement je voudrais savoir est-ce
que ma copine elle va bien elle est chez
vous à l'hôpital votre copine elle
s'appelle Juliette Lefebvre et bien
attendez un instant
ah Julien
chambre 404 écouter elle va bien elle a
un peu de migraine un peu mal au ventre
mais normalement elle sort dans deux
jours mais vous m'avez l'air bien
inquiète pour votre copine ça se fait
que vous êtes inquiète comme ça dimanche
c'est moi Juliette mais comme personne
me dit ce que j'ai ici alors
un petit garçon il va voir son père il
dit papa c'est quoi la beauté il dit tu
vois ta mère il dit oui c'est pas ça du
tout
[Applaudissements]
je vais pas pouvoir aller au bout ce
qu'elle fait rigoler
c'est un couple ils ont ils ont un
enfant mais ils habitent dans un piège
un studio
[Rires]
quand même ils ont mis un code en place
il a dit écoute ce que je vais faire
chez Rico je t'envoie le petit je te dis
j'ai envie de voter ça veut dire que ce
soir on va c'est la fête il est d'accord
il envoie ta mère tu dis que j'ai envie
de voter dis papa il a dit qu'il voulait
voter et dit d'accord ce soir on vote
sauf qu'un jour un matin ils se prenne
un peu la tête l'autre il oublie
l'embrouille avec sa femme il envoie le
petit il va voir ta mère je te dis j'ai
envie de voter ce soir le petit va voir
maman maman papa il veut voter ce soir
écoute tu deviens ton père ce soir il y
a pas de vote alors il revient dit papa
maman elle a dit que ce soir il y avait
pas de vote et l'écoute pas bien je dis
à ta mère que si je vois pas ce soir je
vais aller voter dehors
sa mère dit maman papa il a dit que si
vous votez pas ce soir il allait voter
dehors le décompte mon petit tu dis à
ton père si une voix d'or je l'ouvre un
bureau de vote
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas un truc de fou ça fait 45 ans
qu'on est marié ensemble dis-moi j'ai 70
ans toi tu as 70 ans on est vieux mais
tu te rappelles quand on s'est rencontré
on habitait un petit appartement à
Belleville on avait une petite télé en
noir et blanc on avait pas de voiture on
avait pas d'argent aujourd'hui
on a 200 millions d'euros dans le compte
on habite dans une maison à elle folle
on a 27 télé par chambre on est riche
mais bon je suis avec une femme de 70
ans
sa femme elle regarde c'est très simple
tu as qu'à trouver une petite jeune de
25 ans moi je vais appeler mon avocat et
tu vas retourner à Belleville dans
l'appartement
ça se passe dans un bus le bus il
s'arrête là il y a un mec qui rentre il
s'installe et il regarde à Rabat je
regarde quelque chose se ramène bonjour
tu viens à la sinon non mais pas reconnu
je suis vraiment désolé je vous ai parlé
je suis Dieu
c'est pas possible va s'asseoir derrière
arrivé derrière et ça soit il voit un
autre jeune Edith c'est un truc de fou
si je ne respecte plus rien pourquoi
t'es un mec qui vient de monter il m'a
dit qu'il était Dieu et l'autre il dit
écoute moi j'ai envoyé personne
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sa vie
et son père lui dit écoute je veux pas
venir pour les vacances viens au village
s'il te plaît pour les vacances ça me
ferait du bien c'est que ta mère depuis
qu'elle est morte moi je suis tout seul
et tout viens viens me voir alors il va
y passer les vacances avec son père
pendant 15 jours il était mon fils s'il
te plaît dans le village tout le monde
me demande qu'est-ce que tu fais dans la
vie et je sais pas du coup papa moi je
suis devenu vétérinaire
mon fils qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
vétérinaire pas supprimer s'ils vont pas
comprendre déjà moi déjà j'ai pas
compris qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
écoute moi vétérinaire ben je parle aux
animaux des animaux me parlent il a dit
tiens par exemple tu as vu la petite
chèvre que tu as le dégoûte pas avec
elle depuis que ta mère elle est morte
celle-là tout le monde me demande sur
les réseaux tiens raconte la roche-la
c'est un petit garçon il va voir son
père il dit papa dis-moi pourquoi on a
une djellaba tu sais pourquoi parce que
quand on est dans le désert là j'ai la
batte tu auras pas beaucoup de choses ça
va faire du bien il est d'accord il dit
mais papa pourquoi on me dit des
chaussures bizarres je sais pas des
chaussures bizarres ça c'est des
babouches comme ça quand tu marches dans
le désert le sable ne rentre pas dans
tes pieds il dit mais papa pourquoi on
met un truc là dis ça s'appelle
uncharchia c'est contre le soleil comme
ça quand on est dans le désert le soleil
va pas nous taper il dit pas papa
puisque le si bien équipé contre le
désert qu'est-ce qu'on voit argenté
c'est un mec qui marche dans la rue il
marche dans la rue il a pas d'oser le
mec il est mort dans le film
il voit un bus retourner avec plein de
gens par terre
Isola c'est le coup du refais j'aime
couper une oreille et je vais m'allonger
avec les victimes et ils vont me donner
un billet parce que les assurances donc
ils ont pas un comploter la mal il a dit
ça et tout par terre il s'allonge au
moment où il s'allonge il entend couper
au largeur
[Applaudissements]
laisse-moi faire
tu vas acheter une grande serre dans
cette ferme il va y avoir plein de
vaches et chaque vache elle coûte 2000
euros et c'est vache là ils vont me
faire beaucoup de lait tu vas devenir
milliardaire
ça fait 150 euros tu commences à 150
euros j'ai pas d'argent moi a dit oui
mais c'est 150 euros je vous ai dit la
bonne aventure
ça c'est un homme et une femme qui
travaille il sort en déplacement et à un
moment donné pour dormir reste plus
qu'il chambre eux ils sont mariés chacun
de son côté tu vois c'est pas grave on
est des adultes on peut dormir dans la
même chambre il y a pas de souci aimer
quand même ils ont une chambre avec deux
lits séparés donc ça va en pleine nuit
le monsieur il se réveille excusez-moi
vous pouvez me donner une couverture
parce que j'ai vraiment froid et là la
femme a fait elle lui dit écoutez c'est
ce qu'on va faire pour cette nuit on va
faire comme si on était marié tous les
deux
[Applaudissements]